on est avec toute l'équipe est alors on
a plein de choses aujourd'hui déjà on
vient d'apprendre une très mauvaise vous
le savez puisque l'acteur et humoriste
guy bedos nous a quittés à l'âge de 85
ans on l'a appris il ya quelques minutes
via un post instagram de son fils
nicolas bedos dans lequel il explique il
était beau il était drôle
ils étaient libres et courageux comme je
suis fier de t'avoir eu pour père
embrasse des projets dabadie vu que vous
êtes tous au paradis
voilà on pense et moi sa famille et on
embrasse nicolas bedos voilà voilà voilà
on pense bien sûr à guy bedos immense
humoriste un des plus grands de tous les
temps sur les français enfin les jeunes
ne connaissent peut-être pas mais
c'était une énorme star dans les essarts
80 90 jusqu'à mène déjà 2 il y avait
trois stars et leurs vestes et smaïn
bedos épais et michel boujenah trois
stars vraiment de l'humour dans les
années 80 90 mm michel il est toujours
resté costard smaïni toujours là voilà
mais c'est vrai que voilà c'est plus
jeunes on disait qu'il y avait des
proches des proches et bordeaux se
déplacera sur l'ailé droite et sur
l'ailé gauche bedos et c'était vraiment
les deux humoristes qui faisait rire la
fin il est vrai que guy bedos était
extrêmement engagée aussi politiquement
et à chaque fois et terminé son
spectacle par une revue de presse n'est
assez acide et de c'était très très
drôle c'est une grande perte